founders are people who are
generally very passionate and dedicated
to what they're doing and
that
that keeps me going dealing with people
like that keeps me going they're just
i i enjoy facilitating that kind of
person in achieving their goals that's
always in me
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today i have with me david segal
co-founder of solved4
david is the co-founder of startup
dispute mediation platform solved for
and a partner at wella shaw david is an
unusual startup lawyer in having done
sophisticated legal work in both
transactional and litigation matters he
is an accomplished startup lawyer and
litigator who has extensive experience
in handling a broad range of corporate
transactional and intellectual property
manners including work on multi-million
dollar financing and acquisitions all in
addition to having a deep expertise in
handling complex intellectual property
corporate and commercial litigation
matters
david siegel welcome to 20 minute
leaders all the way from california how
are you today
i'm great thank you for having me
thank you very very much for taking the
time out of your busy schedule to speak
with me a little bit about you know what
it's like being a partner at growella
strong a little bit about your own
journey the founders mentality your way
of partnering with the founders as they
navigate through this really complicated
and convoluted world and and it's it's a
crazy time to be an entrepreneur and to
be alive and you're seeing you know all
the crazy pieces of it and so david tell
me a little bit about yourself and a
little bit about your journey
yeah sure so um i
well i have been a lawyer for
not quite 20 years but um i didn't start
out in the startup world at all i
started out in new york i grew up in new
york um and kind of always knew i wanted
to be a lawyer but thought that meant go
into the courtroom type lawyer
which is how i started i started at a
large law firm in new york and i was
litigating
um you know big
you know bet the company type cases
um and it was interesting but does not
match my personality
um at all
um i'm just uh
i'm not a combative person uh you know
i'm assertive but not aggressive and um
i
i like to bring people together not um
i don't want to i don't want
litigators don't tear people apart good
ones but they but they're fighters more
than um you know uniters and i'm more of
a uniter type person
um so you know i uh i became interested
in the startup world
while i was still in new york and
decided to move out to california
both for family and to kind of pursue
that side of things i left my
big law firm job
perhaps at the wrong time because it was
in the middle of the 08 recession um wow
but it actually worked out very well uh
i i i ended up getting a job in
something totally different and trying
something new and worked at a non-profit
for a while which which i loved but um i
you know
made my way back to the law which was
not a shocker for me and um got uh
hooked up with the law firm at right now
which is guerrilla sha and
our founding partner george grellis is
well known in the legal startup world so
he was a great mentor to have and
um and and still to have um and so from
there i've been at guerrilla shop for
over 10 years working with
startups and founders and trying to
help them succeed and protect their
rights
which is what i've been doing and i'm
loving it
so let's dive deep a little bit into the
relationship between a founding team or
entrepreneurs and and the law firm that
represents them this partnership because
i think from the outside one can you
know intuitively just assume that this
relationship starts and ends at you know
various funding rounds various
legal contracts between employees and
later on perhaps an acquisition or or
potentially an ipo
what how is this relationship actually
managed and how early does it start
um
how early does it start or how early
should it start are two very different
questions
um
i mean
and i and i understand why they diverge
so um you know you're a
you know a student or you're working at
apple facebook whatever company you're
at you have an idea um and
the idea going from an idea to a company
is not a it's not an overnight thing and
it's not it's not clear when that's
gonna happen so
uh you know
founders often kind of tinker around
with something before they know if it's
serious or not and then when they kind
of get serious about it they
um aren't prioritizing legal things that
um often seem to be um
secondary to you know building up kind
of building a product and seeing where
it would go
um
my recommendation is always to
see a lawyer as soon as possible because
um
lawyers in this industry spend an
unfortunate amount of time
cleaning up the issues of not
buttoning up the legal side of things
early
um
which a lot of them can be buttoned up
through you know online platforms you
don't need um
you don't necessarily need a lawyer for
much at the beginning if you're doing
kind of standard things
but if you do nothing at the very
beginning you could end up in situations
where people disagree with what the
setup should be and then you've created
a bunch of ip and who owns it and
um
unclear about who's going to own what in
the company and that can cause problems
um what would that first meeting look
like between
what would that first meeting look like
between you and a founder let's say i'm
coming to you and i'm saying listen
me and my two friends here we're we're
working on this thing nice to meet you
how does this first meeting go
yeah uh so
the first things first is getting an
understanding of what it is that these
people are doing um so um what's the
product what's the market what kind of
what their
um what they're thinking about to get a
sense of
um
the track that the company is on
some early thoughts of some legal issues
they need to think about if they're
going to run into regulatory issues if
there's
um
ip issues at the outset that they need
to be concerned about particularly if
they're working in another company or
still in school or you know that you
know are there issues with them even
owning the ip they're working on
um and then get a sense of of where they
think their trajectory is um
it's not it's not necessarily a fair
assumption that everyone is looking for
traditional vc funding for example
um or if they want to keep their options
open
um for different types of ways of of
growing their business and
that leads to you know recommendations
on what their kind of corporate setup
would be
um
and you know what's market what's not
and
how much
market necessarily matters um and and
what's important to them
going forward right
so in your relationship with founders
you know is it mainly
a
one in which the founders come they give
you an update on what's happening and
then you help facilitate from a legal
perspective what's happening or do you
find yourself also sort of intertwined
with the decision-making process the
brainstorming the the the rationale
behind
what decisions should be made and when
that is
very dependent on the client there are
clients that i have who
come
from time to time and it's it's
transactional in the sense that there's
discrete things they want me to do and
there are clients who
text me all the time and we have calls
about things that are
barely legal
um
it really depends i mean um and you know
on one side you know lawyers who
do what i do
have a lot of repeat experience in ways
that can help that are beyond purely
legal
um
but you know that you know everyone has
the people they you need to work with
people you trust and trust for certain
things and different people have
different people they you know rely on
for different types of decision making i
you know don't begrudge people either
way
where are you on the spectrum so what
you know you've decided to
you've had a quite an interesting
journey throughout your career you
decided to to go back and and now with
gorillas shaw you know represent
founders and work with these founding
teams
what is it about this experience that
you enjoy most
i
there are two sides uh there's not one
answer um on on one hand um
i
i did not i thought i'd be more
interested when i went into this in the
pure tech side of things and and it's
it's interesting that's interesting but
that's not my motivator for staying in
this um
founders are people who are
generally very passionate and dedicated
to what they're doing and
that
that keeps me going dealing with people
like that keeps me going they're just
i i
enjoy facilitating that kind of person
in achieving their goals that's always
in me
on the other side there's the more
um
i don't know how best to put this but um
the
being a lawyer in this in in this
industry allows me in a way that's
constant with my personality it's not
fighting in court um
to exercise a part of my brain that i
enjoy exercising which is the analytical
part of things and i um
being able to do that while
achieving goals that i that you know i
like to achieve is you know
all i could ask for in in a career
i i love that so so david you know as a
young entrepreneur you know sitting now
for the first meeting you know what are
some things that you've been observing
from your experiences that i should you
know be cognizant of things that are
perhaps non-trivial in the founders
journey as i'm navigating this
complicated world with a lot of moving
pieces what are some things that i
should be you know keeping in mind as i
go on my journey
um the first one is founders have a lot
of resources and advice out there
um
and
a lot of it is smart a large
a good amount of it though not nearly
all is well meaning but rarely is it
not loaded in the sense of people having
their own interests
um
and that comes in all sorts of ways um
the most notable is gonna be you know
investors you know potential investors
who
tend to court founders
in a mentory advisory role
when
until they're
on your cap table and funded
it's not a zero-sum relationship but
it's closer to a zero-sum relationship
than founders tend to believe
um
so you have to take the advice you're
getting
with
a grain of salt and that and that comes
from every side i mean the investors
being maybe the biggest but it's an
unfortunate fact that a lot of there's
an ecosystem around the startup the
founder startup world that's filled with
players that are there to give you
advice for
usually equity um and
um
you just have to be careful about whose
advice you're taking and how much you
believe it
right and but then what what skills do
we have to gauge that how do we know
whether this person no either is
qualified or whether you know all the
intentions are aligned with the right
incentives and this is the best partner
for us to work with
sure a couple of things one is
um
do your own due diligence on the people
whose advice you're taking um
investors are going to do diligence on
you you should do diligence on them um
and then and then
i think founders are pretty you know
generally
capable of taking a step back and trying
to figure out
what the motivations might be behind
someone's advice so um
when you're talking i mean there are
professional advisors like lawyers and
you know accountants who have duty like
legal duties to
you know fiduciary duties to you which
which is helpful but then you know you
also have to be somewhat
i don't want to be too much of a skeptic
but you have to be careful about the
advice you're taking in the sense that
um
i think lawyers are generally trying to
give you good advice and so are
accountants but you know if their advice
is something that's going to cost you a
lot of money take a step back and try to
figure out if you know
do you really need that or not um
but
in general doing your diligence and fine
talking to other founders about
who they've dealt with if you're trying
to hire some
company to give you to be a
sales partner of some sort and they're
you know find out who else has worked
with them um there are lots of ways of
of
you know connecting with other founders
um who are usually the best source of
this kind of advice um because
they tend to be very helpful and they
usually don't have much to gain
right now if you're looking at yourself
you know as a part of this whole prism
and this this whole complicated network
you know
why are you in this
why back in new york you say i'm going
to go to california
both for family but also because i want
to be part of the startup scene you're
in silicon valley
you know it's a very hectic world i'm
sure that you know sometimes you have
days that you start them out knowing one
thing you're ending them in a completely
different place with crazy experiences
what is it about you that really gets
you going
um
well i should be honest having lived for
years in manhattan as a lawyer at a big
firm i
saw and still to an extension
my life here as being a step back in
terms of being more caught
up i can imagine so
the hectic the the hectic nature of it
doesn't but i mean
days like that which are most of my days
go very quickly um that that doesn't uh
phase me particularly at all
um and
you know
i deal with a lot of people every day um
who are doing important and exciting
things and
um
yes that makes my life hectic but it
makes my life interesting and i don't
particularly want to be able to predict
how my day's going to end based on how
it begins
so i think and
that's what that's what keeps me going
but what do you have to do then on a
personal level to be able to oh to be
open to that i mean because you know
when i imagined you know the work of a
lawyer i imagined you know pretty strict
schedules you're very on top of things
you know uh
you everything's very orderly and all of
a sudden how how are you able to sort of
train yourself and and set your your own
work environment so that you are
adaptive to these you know urgent
situations that may come in and may
require you to to just shift your
priorities within minutes
um
so i can't do that alone um and uh
i'm not a solo practitioner and and i
wouldn't work as a solo practitioner um
i am
not
quite
i'm not quite that hyper organized
person um but i am a person who knows
how to
work well with others who can help
um
who can help complement the sides of me
that are maybe not my biggest strengths
so
um i know how to i know how to work with
people to you know make sure you know
the things that need to be organized
file-wise and calendar-wise and all that
stuff kept you know keeps getting done
while um
i do the part that i do best
uh it's it's just it's a team effort
right and so just like it's a team
effort for internally within guerrella's
shaw it's also team effort with the
partners that you choose to partner with
which are the entrepreneurs i'm guessing
they don't have to just choose you you
have to choose them what entrepreneurs
do you enjoy working most with what are
sort of their personalities like
sure um
i mean
there's kind of a spectrum
that i enjoy working with there isn't
one type
i
i mostly enjoy working with people who
are
who are there
legal does not need to be and shouldn't
be the most important thing on your list
but it shouldn't be something that
you
don't see any importance in so if if
it's someone who's going to take my
advice and role seriously then chances
are it's going to work quite well
[Music]
i tend to
people tend to for good or bad see me
characterize me as a consigliere type
personality um or playing that kind of
role so
i do enjoy working with clients and that
kind of you know
reach out to me at any time and you know
wanna you know
pick my brain on things um it doesn't
it's not the exclusive way i work and it
you know it probably wouldn't work if
every client was that way but um
[Music]
when we can create a relationship like
that that's something that i do enjoy as
being a part of the client base i work
with but it's not it's not necessarily
just one type uh
right i i gathered that but and then i
think what i you know what i really
gained inspiration from this
conversation is this idea of the
teamwork that goes on here and this idea
of partnership that it's not simply that
there are the more transactional
relationships but really where founders
especially in the early stages can get
the most value it's from gaining that
insight that you're bringing with you
from seeing many many experiences
understanding
who has aligned incentives and what are
the different stakeholders that are here
and sort of navigating through this
complicated web and and david i really
want to thank you for spending this time
with me and for the great work that
you're doing with gorillaz shaw
it was really inspirational for me as a
young entrepreneur and really just thank
you
absolutely happy to do it
i really appreciate it thank you
you